make a note of apology for the idiotic
behavior of my president and I apologize
to Justin Trudeau - and the other people
- the g7 it's disgusting
why people get deeper and more
thoughtful as they get older that is not
the case with Robert De Niro but he's
getting a lot of support from Hollywood
what does this mean for American
politics though does the image of rich
actors swearing at the President and an
awards show help the president or hurt
him Joe Piscopo hosts the Joe Piscopo
show in De Niro's hometown near City he
joins us now from the streets of that
metropolis of 8 million Joe great to see
you Tucker great to see from the Bronx
New York Our Lady of Mount Carmel right
here at a big st. Anthony Festival so
I'm getting my blessings god bless you
my son good good for you I I feel
blessed so what effect it what effect
does this have on normal people do you
think who weren't in the audience or
aren't Huffington Post charter
subscribers how do they react to Robert
De Niro's speech his two-word speech
well from the streets of the Bronx here
you know Belmont Avenue and Arthur
Avenue where the great italian-american
community we idolize Robert DeNiro a
great respect for the brilliance of
Robert De Niro but to go on life to go
on live television
you know from New York I'm telling you
it this will oh this will ensure Donald
Trump's election in 2020 to be that to
be that reprehensible and to be that
vulgar on live television and again I
have such immense respect for this man
but did it just it will resonate with
the rest of the United States of America
because what the president has done you
have to give credit for the g7 summit
was a negotiation the president said we
know you know President Trump announced
the negotiation and then when he goes
and he sits down with kim jeong-hoon
this is monumental it's epic it's
historic and the country is embracing it
and North Korea is embracing it we're
talking about peace here and just to be
to get one of your heroes to be that
vulgar on live television
that doesn't play across the rest of the
United States it's kind of a weird
response because I mean isn't the
argument against Trump that he's vulgar
but it's kind of hard to make that
argument under screaming F Trump in an
awards show yeah that's it that's
exactly right you know I mean it'd be
great if if Bobby De Niro got up there
said I heard some things I heard things
I heard some things you know yeah you
could have fun with it you know are you
talking to me are you talking to me but
you're absolutely right and and the
brilliance of Broadway you know the
greatest entertainers in the world to me
are on the Great White Way you know you
kid those eight shows a week the
brilliance of the Broadway talent oh
yeah then just to take that show and to
take it to that level it really it was
just very very uncomfortable and I'm
being polite well especially since you
know he's made so many great movies he
doesn't need to end this way Joe Piscopo
a great man have fun at the festival
good to see it you know it's like a
positive Johnson says hey god bless you
my son